♪♪
-I'm gonna get to the news.
President Biden visited
the Pentagon on Sunday
to commemorate the anniversary
of the September 11th attack
and said, "It's not enough
to stand up
for democracy once a year."
"I don't know, I'm making it
work," said Joe Manchin.
[ Laughter ]
White House officials
are reportedly holding
emergency meetings to prevent
a potential national
railroad strike,
but just in case,
Biden's ready if you need him.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke
about his infrastructure plan
yesterday in Boston.
Said one Boston resident,
"Wow, I've never gotten a DUI
on a paved road before."
[ Laughter ]
We could have given him a shirt.
According to the latest numbers
from the Bureau of Labor
statistics, gas prices
have decreased
for 89 consecutive days,
or as Fox News reported it,
"Biden leaves oil markets
in shambles."
[ Laughter ]
Buckingham palace will
reportedly only extend
invites to Queen Elizabeth's
funeral to current
heads of state,
and no former presidents,
which is a bummer 'cause we all
kind of wanted to hear
that eulogy.
"Elizabeth, she loved
everyone at Hogwarts."
[ Laughter ]
"Even the gingers,
even the gingers."
[ Laughter ]
"And if she were here,
I -- I know what she would say.
She would say January 6th
was mostly antifa."
[ Laughter ]
Apple yesterday released
its IOS 16 software,
which will allow iPhone users
to unsend messages,
and not a moment too soon.
[ Laughter ]
The Emmy Awards ceremony
was held last night.
Our show was nominated
and, honey,
clear some space on the mantle,
cause they had snow globes
at the airport.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience "awws" ]
[ Applause ]
Elon Musk's college girlfriend
is auctioning off
personal items
from their relationship,
including photographs,
a birthday card
and upwards of three kids.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience "ohs" ]
That's why we win
the snow globes, baby.
[ Laughter ]
Princeton University
announced last week
it will cover all costs
for undergraduate students
for families making
less than $100,000 a year.
Said school officials,
"It's not their fault
their parents went to Brown."
[ Audience "ohs" ]
That's the sort of cutting
ivy league humor...
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according to a new
survey, 26% of Americans
said that if they were
reading a book
and not enjoying it,
they would still finish it.
"Thank you," said Dan Brown.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden and
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
made a surprise trip
to Delaware yesterday
to cast their votes
in the state's primaries.
Though for what it's worth,
Biden just voted
the same way he always does.
"Ah, simpler times."
President Biden today
toured the Detroit Auto Show.
And you're not
going to believe this.
He traded the presidential limo
for a '72 Chevelle straight up.
MyPillow C.E.O. Mike Lindell
said in an interview yesterday
that FBI agents
seized his cellphone at
a Hardee's drive-through
in Minnesota.
The FBI says they weren't tipped
off about his location.
They just assumed.
"Hey, they want us to get
Lindell's cellphone."
"Alright.
Hardee's drive-through?"
That's right -- MyPillow C.E.O.
Mike Lindell said
that FBI agents
seized his cellphone
at a Hardee's drive-through.
So not a great way
to start his job interview.
After the death of
Queen Elizabeth,
Britain's Prince William
reportedly inherited
a 685-year-old estate
worth $1 billion,
which I think makes him
a suspect.
President Biden said yesterday
during a celebration
at The White House
that his recently passed
Inflation Reduction Act
is a win for the middle class.
"Thanks," said the one guy
still in it.
That's right --
President Biden hosted
a celebration at
The White House yesterday.
They were originally going to
ask The Beach Boys,
but Biden said, "Let's get
someone the kids will like."
So, we -- Can we go back there?
What did I miss?
Go back. Yeah, okay.
One more card.
So, we missed the part
that James Taylor played at it.
And that's a detail we call
"key to the joke."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now -- now,
halfway through the joke,
I realized the problem, guys.
But I also --
There was no way --
And I feel like
I'm pretty good on my feet.
There was no way
for me to fix it.
Here's how it would have looked
if I tried to fix it
the way I thought I would.
Alright, ready?
Wally, thank you.
That's right -- President Biden
hosted a celebration
at The White House yesterday,
and they were gonna --
James Taylor was there.
They were gonna originally --
And they asked James Taylor --
They were going to originally
ask The Beach Boys.
How you feeling, Wally?
-I'm not sure
that was my mistake.
-Okay.
Yeah. Yeah, that's true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's always been a gray area
where cue cards land...
-Yeah.
-...and your responsibility.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-During -- Well,
since he's wearing a mask,
let's edit him saying,
"Sorry, Seth."
During the event yesterday,
President Biden
wore aviator sunglasses.
Although, at this point,
it would be a big deal
if he wore any
other kind of sunglasses.
Yeah, see? Now, that's news.
Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham
introduced a bill yesterday
that would
ban abortions after 15 weeks
of pregnancy nationwide,
but just 'cause his
first pitch of banning sex
in general proved unpopular.
According to a new survey,
67% of Americans said that they
are vaccinated against polio,
while the other 33% texted,
"Mom, am I vaccinated
against polio?"
Ferrari yesterday
unveiled its first-ever
four-door vehicle, which will be
an S.U.V.-like sports car
with a 715-horsepower engine.
Perfect for taking your third
wife's kids to soccer practice.
And, finally,
NBC is set to premiere
a new show next month starring
the Harlem Globetrotters.
It's called
"Chicago Globetrotters."
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Let's see if Wally
got that card right.
Oh, well, I guess that wasn't
the problem, then.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke to
Britain's King Charles yesterday
for the first time since
Queen Elizabeth's passing.
"I can't believe you waited your
entire life for this lousy job,"
said both of them
at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
A possible national railroad
strike was averted today
after 20 hours of talks between
the union's leadership
and labor negotiators
from the railroads.
20 hours of talks
that were very annoying
to everyone else
in the quiet car.
[ Laughter ]
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
told reporters
at her press conference
yesterday
that she expects Democrats to
introduce legislation next month
to regulate stock trading
among members of Congress.
Or as she told her stockbroker,
"Sell!"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new book,
then White House Chief of Staff
John Kelly was so angry
when former President Trump
refused to lower the flag
after Republican Senator
John McCain died
that he told Trump,
"When you die,
the public will come to
your grave and piss on it."
[ Laughter ]
And if you think the line to see
the Queen is long...
[ Laughter ]
According to the same book...
We're just --
This is just book reports.
[ Laughter ]
This is --
Nothing here is political.
We're just reporting on a book.
[ Laughter ]
According to the same book,
the heir to cosmetics company
Estee Lauder
suggested to former
President Trump
that the U.S. buy Greenland.
It would have been
the first time Trump listened
to a cosmetics employee.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump visited
his Virginia golf club this week
as it reportedly
undergoes renovations
ahead of a Saudi-backed
LIV Golf tournament.
He also helped oversee
packing VIP gift bags.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Kansas recently set
a Guinness World Record
for largest collection of
Kansas City Chiefs memorabilia,
with more than 1,000 pieces,
while a man in Cleveland set
a Browns memorabilia record
with two.
[ Laughter ]
Starbucks yesterday announced
a new growth plan
which will add thousands
of new U.S. stores.
Don't believe me?
Look behind you.
[ Laughter ]
Pretty nice living room.
The pilot of a rescue helicopter
that reportedly left behind
a stranded hiker
said that he thought
the man was just waving hi.
[ Laughter ]
Even worse, the hiker
was actually waving
at another helicopter
behind him.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, singer Adele
this week
put her Beverly Hills mansion
up for sale.
She said she has a lot of happy
memories in the house,
which explains why we've never
heard a song about it.
And that...
[ Laughter ]
...was a closer!
That was a monologue, everybody.
♪♪